jede frau präsidentin kollegen und
kollegen
38 prozent der menschen in deutschland
fällt es zunehmend schwer die dinge des
täglichen bedarfs zu bezahlen man kann
nicht mehr von einer minderheit sprechen
das sagte anja pohl fotos seiner sendung
börse vor acht butter kostet inzwischen
über drei euro so 05 euro mit dem
discounter schon ein euro 20 frisches
obst und gemüse werden zunehmend zum
luxusgut
eine solche preissteigerung habe ich
seit langer zeit nicht mehr erlebt das
sagte mir neulich eine 93 jährige dame
aus meinem wahlkreis zum glück zum glück
fahre sie kein auto mehr sagte sie die
spritpreise heute könnte sie mit ihrer
kleinen rente nicht bezahlen das neun
euro ticket das hält sie für eine gute
idee aber wo sie wohnt da fährt fast
kein bus und die schon gut wenn man sich
das chaos in der umsetzung mal anschaut
dann könnte man meinen an die steuer sei
noch im amt
von den 300 euro in der die pauschale
wird sie als rentnerin auch nichts sehen
anders übrigens als minister minister
der bundesregierung auch sie herr scholz
sie bekommen die energie pauschale die
alte dame nicht ja wie abgehoben kann
man eigentlich sein dass du wirklich in
skandalen und da wundern sie sich dass
viele leute nicht zur wahl gehen weil
sie das vertrauen in politik verloren
haben solche gesetze schreiben die
spaltung der gesellschaft voran herr
scholz das müssen doch auch sie
inzwischen mal merken wir haben seit
über zwei jahren mit den auswirkungen
der bewohner pandemie zu kämpfen viele
menschen sind ausgelaugt die
bundesregierung hat immer noch keinen
plan herr lauterbach fürchtet dass im
herbst die infektionszahlen wieder nach
oben gehen können sind wir darauf
eigentlich vorbereitet gibt es
inzwischen zb die noch personal in den
krankenhäusern
ich werde ihnen sagen nein woher soll es
auch kommen sie haben nichts aber auch
gar nichts an den schlechten
arbeitsbedingungen für die pflegerinnen
und pfleger verbessert nicht mal den
pflege bonus haben alle bekommen bevor
nichts kommt nun mal nicht so lauterbach
viele menschen viele menschen die
blicken mit großer sorge in die zukunft
so unsicher wie jetzt war das leben
hierzulande lange nicht mehr zwei
flugstunden von uns entfernt druck
coatings krieg in der ukraine seit über
drei monaten sterben dort tag für tag
menschen tausende sind auf der flucht
die weitere entwicklung und auch die
auswirkungen sind vollkommen ungewiss
außerdem geht der klimawandel weitgehend
ungebremst voran auch erbe fördert die
soziale spaltung hierzulande und in der
welt fakt ist diese bundesregierung gibt
keine sozialen antworten auf die krisen
unserer zeit und das geht so nicht
kollegen
beginnen wir mit dem schlagen
lebenshaltungskosten hier braucht es
dringend eine wirksame staatliche
preisaufsicht für lebensmittel energie
damit schluss ist mit den mondpreisen es
braucht direktzahlungen die die realen
preissteigerungen auch wirklich abfedern
es braucht einen schutzschirm die
betroffenen unternehmen und beschäftigte
gerade auch im hinblick auf das
bevorstehende öl embargo das die lage
deutlich verschärfen wird es braucht
eine echte offensive zur schaffung von
bezahlbarem wohnraum besonders in
ballungsgebieten den wohnraum darf kein
luxus sein es ist ein menschenrecht und
ja und ja wir brauchen entschlossene
maßnahmen im kampf gegen den klimawandel
aber dafür muss man auch bereit sein in
klimaschutz zu investieren in die
notwendige transformation vor allem in
die dekarbonisierung der wirtschaft
erneuerbare energien all das muss aber
auch einher gehen mit klaren
perspektiven und einer sicherung von
arbeitsplätzen klimaschutz der kann nur
gelingen wenn er sozial gerecht ist dass
sie war
aber was macht stattdessen die
bundesmittel für
keine der aufgezeigten probleme sind im
haushalt auch nur ansatzweise genügend
mittel eingestellt im bereich sozialen
wohnungsbau wissen sie ja nicht mal wie
viele die einstellen müssten um ihre
zahl von 100.000 sozialwohnungen pro
jahr zu erreichen das kann eine anfrage
meiner kollegin karin ein aufgedeckter
so wirklich ein skandal die
explodierenden energiekosten
gibt es flüchtige entlastungs päckchen
die realen mehrkosten werden nicht mal
im ansatz ausgeglichen einmalig bis zu
300 euro das lächerlich studierende
bringt aber und rentner wie gesagt den
komplett leer aus das einfach unerhört
und hubertus heil der will jetzt mit
einem sozial gestaffelten klima geld
nachbessern schön aber dafür müssen wir
halt erstmal eigenes kabinett überzeugen
da kommt er jetzt schon eine menge
gegenwind und selbst wenn es kommen
sollte dann frühestens anfang denn
jahres in welcher höhe keiner weiß ist
das wirklich absurd kolleginnen und
kollegen
bei all dem
macht man sich doch zu recht für wen
machen sie eigentlich politik bei damen
und herren von der ampel für die 38
prozent der menschen in unserem land die
kaum noch über die runden kommen sicher
nicht aber
es gibt durchaus leute die von ihrer
politik profitieren die aktionäre von
netiq konzern zum beispiel die freuen
sich gerade über rekordgewinne der
ölmulti shell hat gerade verkündet dass
seine gewinne um 43 prozent gestiegen
sind man könnte diese krassen
krisengewinner steuerlich abschöpfen das
macht italien zum beispiel wir haben das
als linke hier mehrfach eingebracht mit
diesen steuerlichen mehreinnahmen könnte
man die menschen entlasten aber das
scheint für sie unvorstellbar ich bin
unglaublich ja
er wissen sie alle alle superreichen in
deutschland können sich darauf verlassen
dass diese bundesregierung unter ihnen
unter keinen umständen an das prall
gefüllte bankkonto geht und zwar egal
wie groß die not ist denn wo ist die
vermögenssteuer liebe spd liebe grünen
im wahlkampf waren sie danach voll dafür
da haben sie doch noch verstanden dass
zum beispiel der lidl chef schwarz
dessen vermögen in einem jahr um sage
und schreibe 16 milliarden euro
gestiegen ist dass der
selbstverständlich einen angemessenen
anteil dafür das gemeinwohl zurückführen
müsste aber setzt in der regierung sind
kein wort mehr von einer vermögenssteuer
und
bei wem knallen diese woche um die
sektkorken so richtig genau bei den
aktionären der rüstungskonzern weil sie
an diesem freitag allen ernstes unser
grundgesetz ändern wollen um 100
milliarden schweres auf rüstungsprogramm
hineinzuschreiben seit der großen
ankündigung dieses auf rüstungsprogramms
ist der aktienkurs von rheinmetall
bereits um 100 prozent gestiegen merken
100 milliarden euro für rüstung und das
obwohl der wert bereits heute weil 50
milliarden euro pro jahr liegt er es
jahr für jahr gestiegen ist einfach
falsch dachte abgesicherte wurde jahr
für jahr ist er angestiegen trotzdem
behaupten sie die 100 milliarden wären
notwendig um die bundeswehr fit zu
machen muss man klar zu sagen natürlich
muss die bundeswehr in der lage sein
ihren grund gesetzlichen auftrag die
landesverteidigung zu erfüllen aber dass
sie das heute nicht kann das liegt nicht
an zu wenig geld auch der
bundesrechnungshof sagt man müsse klären
ob nicht andere gründe ursächlich sind
für die mangelnde einsatzbereitschaft zb
strukturelle defizite bei der
organisation der bundeswehr wir wissen
doch das ist ein eklatantes
missmanagement gibt und das ist auch der
grund für die probleme nicht so wenig
geld dass die wand
um es ganz klar zu sagen
dieses sondern ist gegenüber den
millionen menschen in unserem land die
existenzielle sorgen und nöte haben
einfach eine unverschämtheit ich kann
das nicht glauben aber
auch viele politisch ist es verheerend
eine auf rüstungsspirale macht die welt
nicht friedlicher das wissen wir doch
das gegenteil ist der fall man dass die
union das die fdp mit so einer politik
keine probleme haben das keine
überraschung aber kolleginnen und
kollegen von der spd sie kommen aus der
tradition von willy brandt kolleginnen
und kollegen von den grünen sie kommen
doch aus der friedensbewegung
100 milliarden euro für ausrüstung ins
grundgesetz schreiben das doch irrsinn
machen sie da doch nicht mit
der prinz
ich würde mal sagen
waffenlieferungen in kriegsgebiete zu
sein insbesondere gegen schwere
waffenlieferung das hat nichts mit
pazifismus zu tun wir haben das hier vor
kurzem einmal dargestellt hat es hat
etwas mit vernunft zu tun russland ist
die größte atommacht der welt den
militärischen mitteln ist dieser krieg
nicht zu gewinnen es braucht
deeskalation ist auch diplomatie es
braucht wirksamer sanktionen gegen die
russische führung gegen die mächtigen
oligarchischen damit möglichst schnell
der krieg endet darin die mitte links
noch nicht ausgeschöpft und das wissen
sie auch und
[Applaus]
sie haben versprochen und er ihnen ja
ich weiß dass führen sie ungern ist aber
die wahrheit sie haben versprochen unter
ihnen als finanzminister wird ist keine
schulden geben keine neuen schulden
geben was sie hier aber irreführend als
sondervermögen bezeichnen ist in
wirklichkeit nichts anderes ist sind
neue schulden plötzlich geht es für
alles andere soll aber ab 2023 die
schuldenbremse wieder gelten diese
schuldenbremse wegen der arbeit jahren
während der seit jahren immer wieder
heißt es sei kein geld da die
schuldenbremse wegen der städte und
gemeinden immer öfter schwierigkeiten
haben öffentliche schwimmbäder
bibliotheken jugendclubs oder sogar
frauenhäuser offen zu halten die
schuldenbremse wegen des verheerenden
einem er jedoch investitionsstock gibt
weil straßen brücken und dem
schienennetz von schnellem internet will
ich gar nicht anfangen herr lindner sagt
wir müssen an unsere kinder und enkel
denken deshalb bräuchte es die
schuldenbremse aber
das ist volkswirtschaftlich leider
völliger und denn selbst denn selbst die
sprichwörtliche schwäbische hausfrau die
angela merkel damals als kronzeugin für
die einführung der schuldenbremse bemüht
hat als sinnbild für eine ordentlich
wirtschaftende person selbst die
schwäbische hausfrau würde einen kredit
aufnehmen um ihr kaputtes dach zu
sanieren statt es einfach rein regnen zu
lassen insbesondere in sulz ins zeit ja
ja wir müssen unsere kinder und enkel
denken und deshalb dürfen wir ihn doch
kein verfallenes haus hinterlassen das
ist doch die wahrheit kolleginnen und
kollegen wir brauchen investitionen für
unsere zukunft zum beispiel für den
konsequenten ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien und er habe meinten sie
eigentlich dass mit progressiver politik
wenn sie für aufrüstung wenn sie auf
brust und 100 milliarden bereitgestellt
werden die investitionen in erneuerbare
energien aber unter dem vorbehalt der
schuldenbremse stehen oder wenn sie ihre
umweltziele einfach aufgeben und sich
für fracking gas terminals einsetzen
oder zulassen dass das weltnaturerbe
wattenmeer durch gasbohrungen gefährdet
wird wir erzählen sie das eigentlich
ihren wählerinnen ist mir ein rätsel ich
denke ich denke es ist klar geworden
warum wir diesen haushalt nicht
zustimmen können er ist nicht sozial und
zutiefst ungerecht und dazu können wir
als linke niemals jahr
[Applaus]